yeah hey I means I'm the senior
rendering engineer for Crytek and I'm
here to share a bit of the experience
what happens when you drop Robin zone on
a mobile phone
Robin zone is actually a VR game that is
about little boys training on the planet
and we published that in 2016 for psvr
and then later for HTC vive and oculus
rift so that are actually very different
platforms that ps4 is my architecture
just like mobile phone and the other
ones are PC we had numerous differences
built into the engine so when we tackle
working on the mobile phone we didn't
have to change very much to get optimal
streaming and stuff like that because
memory management is very important and
you don't want to copy stuff around
which you already have in your mobile
device for us that was basically a
learning experience we had the hope to
support DVR with Vulcan which wasn't the
case back then GDC 2017 and still today
working has where no connection to any
VR interface at the moment the in droid
system part of the CryEngine we didn't
need to touch because in 2015 for GDC we
made an equally quick and dirty hack for
our Crysis 3 MP multiplayer on a Tegra
device that Tegra device was much more
powerful than Android mobile device
and OpenGL so basically that was an
exercise and orientation and evaluating
I was the performance of the GPU what
what are the tools that we have and how
we can improve on that and I brought the
demon yeah so I think it runs at 1920 by
1080 this is a loading screen and this
is a sequence from the beginning of the
game obviously not VR because we don't
want we have we don't have the
capability to write everything which is
in the regular oculus driver was as on
chroma submissions and air tracking and
all of this which we would have to make
ourselves which obviously is possible by
default it's on Rails and you can't hear
it sadly that actually Hix which is this
little AI in in the ball with AI is
talking to us and there sounds in the
background and for fun he also made it
very difficult to see made it react to
the orientation of the cellphone
it's kind of sad but I mean you you can
come forward after the talk and then you
can try to save it's not a big deal
as you saw it runs about at 45 frames
per second sometimes a bit better
sometimes it was we also experimented
with the Nexus 6p which was I would say
a failure in the Samsung s7 this is a
version with an X in US and Mali T 880
the Nexus 6p has an inertia which has
severe limitations
okay so regarding workin' we reworked
the entire cranium over the last years
to be more abstract and usually it was
entirely dx11 models or even though
general that we used on the Tegra device
was actually on G DX xi o nga
translation so this time we made
everything abstract and all our the API
said we are supporting like eleven and
twelve and we can and so on as natively
integrated and has all the optimizations
ps4 Xbox and so on so this was not our
first attempt at weaken our PC version
ran relatively stable at the time but it
was our first attempt
we're running working on a mobile device
our Android preach is sta open-source
project and there was no mmm no
support at that time so I ripped out an
entire default OpenGL context
initialization which happens by default
and used our regular VK surface in the
casebook chain
functionality that we had to create the
necessary objects working objects to run
on an android window when we ran it just
like that a lot of bad things and no
validation errors were generated the in
the rest introspection when we tried to
find out what happened on the the under
a chip it only supported for the script
tables stage and stuff like that without
any validation validation there besides
that there were tons of formats which
were not supported I mean Robinson ran
on the regular PC GPUs which one support
block compression so we had to find
corresponding mappings to yeah
luckily the the a support film was
already in place because our open G
implementation had all the EAC
coatings enabled then there were some
surprising fails there were specific
Esmond targets which weren't available
we met them to have performance were
some I think under in both I'm not sure
which of them didn't support 32-bit
float that stands and then we had to go
back to the 16 there was also a problem
getting something as basic as red 16
which was an integral format seeing a
single channel and check out format
which would actually aliens the D 16 so
we had problems actually accessing the
stick 16 by awliyas interviews we didn't
pick ASTC over AC because where we just
worked one month on it and it was just
an experiment so it's not that that we
have to make the whole featureless
complete so basically we ran through the
code and made large part of the code
base flex was the situation where the
requested swaption mode of FIFO wasn't
available and we had to get back to
mailbox there was a situation that you
asked for triple buffering as well that
you get three back buffers and you
actually got four there was the problem
with the specific texture formats and
like for example the Mali t-80 on this
s7 does not have anisotropic filtering
on the Andre no we don't have any cube
arrays or 3d samplers and where the
geometry shader and tessellation
subfolders all over the place most of
them basically don't support any of that
and there's a problem as well if you're
from a PC environment you know that you
always combined a trainer targets and
you basically have unlimited descriptors
and/or you have 256 HLS area slots and
all of this the numbers are not very
much most of the time it's foreign no
targets sometimes you have because of a
bug just run descriptor table sometimes
you have few descriptor a for descriptor
table so you have to keep the engine
running and all of these restrictions
and just not quit and say oh sorry
you can't run that is not necessarily
problem to allow the system to downcast
the smoker mode that's not a big deal if
you're using FIFO or mailbox or
something like that you can write the
code so that the texture formats can
downcast to compatible formats that are
available it's just you have to make a
lot of reflection and on the device and
see what you can do in the case if you
really need a 3d texture it becomes a
bit complicated but I mean having
alternatives that really the algorithmic
alternatives is always a good thing
our shaders
[Music]
so when we supported the opengl we had a
transcoder that translated HLS 800 GLSL
which was a child SNCC which was also
used in unity we heavily modified it we
added to compute rate a support and all
kinds of different sample type supports
and so on so that thing became feature
complete and the end basically the
problem is that an avoiding GLSL is not
really enough work until as a week in
specific year less air with different
annotations and different syntaxes and
so I had to go over HL SLCC again and
make a lot of adjustments like how to
pass metadata from HLSL to Spivey
because you want to reflect on the
sperry basically this is an exercise and
masochism I would say so luckily
luckily this is over because now we have
I think it's called
DXE odbc we have a native HLSL test baby
translator which has been developed by
Kronos together with a few folks of
Google so this is not anymore but we
don't wanna repeat it so we are ending a
lot of adopt early adopter issues even
after we thought we make everything
right and we adapt to all the different
parameters of these devices like we said
on the PC I ran the 100 validation
errors on the devices there were no
validation errors but sometimes it was
completely broken or it looked slightly
different specific parts of it look
different flickered or some constant
puffs are various when translated
transferred to the to the draw in a
correct way or something again you know
we don't know really what happened there
so on the Andrea like I said there was
absolutely humid area supports or we
limited to one cube map there were
problems with with the constant buffers
so we actually made big areas in the
shaders where we had coded lights like
for example for this demo this is not
because of performance reasons this is
really because the device just didn't or
the driver just didn't do what we told
him to do yeah and then there was a
problem on andrina which was a relative
severe we couldn't actually toggle the
script or tables so we bound one
monstrous descriptor table and we
dynamically offset it with
well coil which is a solution several
basic all of us solutions just to make
the demo running yet I kind of recommend
that you try something like that for
delivering a game so after it ran with
the expected result the next problem was
performance where this is Robinson which
means that our baseline performance is a
ps4 the subsequent releases on on Steam
and on the oculus tour for PCs which
means open-ended you can run it on a
Titan so there were no problems this is
a comparison between an s7 and my ps4
which is in some ways very severe here
the CPU is a Exynos MP 12 which is a 2.3
gigahertz 4 core it runs and big.little
I think so in theory we could have eight
but we could only use for these
gigaflops are without neon neon as is a
vectorization instruction for which if
you would use it what quadruple the Jiva
gigaflops which means you would be at
9.2 there's a hundred 2.4 gigahertz in
this demo it's not such a big problem
because we don't have any collision
detection we don't have any complex CPU
code but if you were to actually
try to calculate any of that and there
are some problems with water cure the
GPU is in the similar ballpark the Molly
T 880 has 260 gigaflops vs. 1.8
teraflops of the ps4 mmm basically that
this gigaflops don't necessarily mean
that much
you also have favorite limitations you
have that extra pot leaping limitations
and so on so this is just like a rough
rough idea about what this the biggest
problem actually even if it doesn't
really look like that is the memory
bandwidth on the ps4 we have gddr5
shared between CPU and GPU and on the sm
we have NDP ddr4 which has low power
ddr4 which is actually double rate so
it's 28.7 gigabyte per second was 176
given per second and this because we're
having we implement in the for trading
we have a lot of post-processing effects
which are fullscreen effects our Costas
basically proposed our deport the cost
of everything after the G buffer is as
proportional to the resolution and the
band of cost is proportional to
the resolution as well so you can run a
very small resolution and run the whole
pipeline or you have to make cuts and
then there are the thermal issues which
we completely ignored but this device
behaves very nice the Tegra that we ran
three years ago was running hot after
five minutes and was throttling which
didn't happen with this which is pretty
nice
so the rendering framework of Robinson
is a fully tired if our trading pipeline
we're running Jeevitha pass which means
all the drawers are writing out material
attributes in two different render
targets and we are storing depth and
then afterwards we can do all kinds of
magic things with like you know screen
space I do the lighting depth of motion
all of these things can be done on this
tree buffer here we have three three
bound Rhino targets each one is
fortunate 8-bit which means we have
about 24 bytes in three render targets
and its relative few rate heavy use a
lot of capacities of the ROPS and if you
look at the pure memory bandwidth
occupation just looking at it that's
about almost a gigabyte per second you
can just look 28 times at such a buffer
on mobile device and then you eat up all
your bandwidth so that is pretty
problematic that is just one two five
sixty by fourteen
so we had to find an alternative
in the beginning we experimented with
4-bit render targets decide between a
target so that would then go to 1212
bite but we still would be robbed
limited because we still have three men
that hangs bound so our idea was we
reduced the entire 3/3 render target in
buffer to singer four component render
target in a previous version of crisis
we already employed the technique that
we are storing some information just on
even and returning information on
offenses which results in a half size
rendering and not a quarter size running
but a half size rendering here we saw a
video at full resolution so
the basic nonmetallic surface color is
full resolution and then we are storing
normal smoothness and reflectance at all
turning positions like you see in the
little square there the reflectance is
non-color we could get away with it in
this demo but normally you would
actually have want to have color to
reflectance which needs more time so we
just wanted to see how fast what we get
CryEngine running without major
modifications can we actually get into
the direction of your performance so
here we have examples of this tiny micro
G bhava so they are the three render
times double one is the RGB part and the
lower one is the a part so this really
just three render targets and everything
all these six things in those two zoom a
bit nearer you see the cost the cost is
that of course your under sampling your
edges and you sometimes see that every
even odd line just forms a diagonal
except instead of like the regular
diagonal that you have in the full
resolution G buffer the meaning of the
returning pixels years are also not
always the same so it's a bit difficult
to label this it's just that you get
idea what's the price we actually have a
tree where a reconstruction of this
in the in the knighting pass it comes
out in acceptable quality in other areas
like we render HDR and we tone with the
HDR later other bandwidth savings we
reach by reducing the the precision of
the HDR buffer from regular half to 11
bit half even lower precision floating
point representations we kicked stencil
out so that we could use 16 instead of D
24 s 8 and Robinson is a VR game already
for fights a lot of the effects we don't
have depth of field we don't have motion
blur because all of this stuff just in
the VR device environment breaks the
illusion that you are really in the same
breaks immersiveness so we had to turn
off a lot of the additional nice making
post-processing effects like the
subsurface scattering because of a
require space and Jeevitha
we also don't have a nice green space
reflection because it eats way too much
bandwidth it's basically right racing
race and screen space which probably
eats up the entire bandwidth that we
have no volumetric fog that's the 3d
texture back then we wouldn't have had
an alternative like two-dimensional fork
or something like that
and of all the madness out of all the
other post-processing effects we only
need a tone mapping and the vignette
effect so that you you have the
simulation of a reduced rate of you
and we made one one uber shader out of
this which looking at the bandwidth is I
think the correct suggestion that you
merge or the post-processing audio
screen space passes if possible into one
big shader because the ALU capacity of
the mobile GPU is way above the
bandwidth so instead of read/write
read/write read/write it's better to
just read once and then drop 5,000
instruction shader and then only right
ones all right so our conclusion of the
project regarding games on Android the
effort to make woken run on the mobile
platform from our PC platform was
relative minor we were four people
working one month on it so you could
basically say one of us worked one month
on polishing or the problematic cases of
working on mobile the biggest problem is
the variety of targetable Hardware like
me hat in the talks before you can make
a business decision like oh it's not
viable to target this and that much
harder but there's a software engineer
you also have the problem there's tons
of hardware which is almost equivalent
and there's just one checkbox missing or
he is just one checkbox missing so you
have to write your engine relative
flexible that you can adapt yourself to
it we also didn't really believe that
like every what right now this in stereo
then we would be at 20:20 fps maybe
which was way way below what is
supported by by a person an AVR device
but if we didn't really expect that that
happen but basically if we have GPU that
is twice as powerful as t8 84 moly then
we actually might get into the direction
of having something like this in VR on a
mobile device we were very happy that in
principle it was possible to run fully
fully physically based shading pipeline
on a mobile device with actually higher
deferred rendering and forward plus and
while I didn't observe any compute Q and
working on any of these test devices I'm
pretty sure that the modern mobile
devices are coming up with a complete
queue earlier than later
working is very well positioned because
the CPU overhead is very low you have a
lot possibility to control your GPU
performance you can submit stuff in
different ways that's contrary to OpenGL
which has very large black box it's
difficult to optimize for it because I
mean the driver can make something and
then you don't know about it and
everything it did was wasn't wayne why
for working everything is relative way
defined the conclusion for working on
Android
already announced a few of those the
good part is that in working you can do
multi-threaded rendering now entire
renderer is actually submitting the big
scene graphs in a multi-threaded way
this is very very difficult in OpenGL
you can open concurrent contexts but I
wouldn't I wouldn't suggest that it's
probably not rather what's very nice is
actually the renderer sub passes of
working which requires usually factoring
of your engine it basically means that
little tiles of your shader one one's
through the whole process let's say you
have ten passes so then this tyre has
run ten times and then another tile has
run ten times and so on so you're having
the possibility in the driver to
actually merge parts of that using
optimal memory i/o and stuff like that
but that requires making dedicated
changes in the architecture so at the
end I want to thank everyone who
participated Alex by myself
Te'o Matias Nicole and the other Nicol
and without the guys working on these
tools almost nothing of this would have
been possible HLS CC is an open-source
project
which we could manipulate give back
speed across yes I think from Kronos now
STL to done that stuff since years and
we have probably used a few more open
source to chains to make all this weird
stuff happen
well we don't have any official support
and special things to Liam and is on the
theory why actually they are working on
the DX e which is this new speed
back-end which removes all the
problematic things with shaders and try
attack us hiring so if you want to work
on mobile for for the CryEngine
questions is it looks to me that most of
some of your bandwidth problems could be
alleviated by most peeling the tile
after every pass when you mentioned that
that would require a react attack
shirring of the of the engine is that a
problem of resources in a sense that it
would take you a long time to react it
at the engine or is the problem of the
API that is not making your life easier
no the problem is that
the last missing piece and the CryEngine
is that we don't have a render graph the
big API makers evangelizing the idea
that you submit the whole frame work as
a render graph and if you generate the
render graph dynamically every frame
like you don't write the render graph
and code and you're CPP and it's static
if you have a manager that generates a
render graph every frame to schedule all
of this then you can actually generate
random sub passes for work on
automatically because you have to
specify okay this is an input which
state is this input is this clear
do I read from it is a read modify write
and so on saying you have to annotate a
lot of the struts that you use
generating so passes on working and it's
not recommendable to make this manually
so you have to have an automated system
to generate random graphs in in data in
memory and then it's the trivial thing
yes and then move on to the next title
yeah that's that's yeah that's even
independent in working you have the
possibility like what we saw in in this
capture tools you had the render targets
where you write to and you have the
depth sensor and if you express
something sub passes and workin' you're
basically describing a chain of shaders
how they interact with each other how
they feeling data from one shader pass
to a next shader facets similar to how
do we describe in the shader stages
between vertex shader and
shade and how they interacting with each
other in the data transportation way so
on working you have one step above that
so that you're basically putting entire
draw us into relation to subsequent
roles and that brings a lot of
performance can potentially bring a lot
of performance like we have the
imagination ships which actually ships
which have hardware support for for this
mechanism so it doesn't spill to memory
we have this problem that a p/e ddr4 is
very slow so the imagination ship has an
on-chip pasa where he spills the data
between the different sub passes not
into main memory he spills into a
special dedicated piece of hardware and
you can maybe get away with ten times
speed up by that as the bandwidth of
this internal area of the chip is just
ten times faster than ap ddr4
you mentioned texture formats did you
guys use etc' too
or did you find that not sufficient or I
mean inside is DC know for us it's not
sufficient we are almost using every
texture format Under the Sun I believe
it's the only one across all Android
yeah no there we had permutations of the
etc' - which provides one channel to
channel and addition a bit depth until
11 bit and and are you going to continue
with your experimentation are you gonna
wait for mobile to get a little bit
better maybe a defense on how fast of XR
is going to finalize there is an
initiative from Chronos called open XR
which encapsulate open a are open mr and
open vr where they wanna attach welcome
to and then we have a really our
interface and then we definitely back
experimenting I mean the problem for us
is it's the gap between the ps4 which is
our regular min spec and the next
movement anyways
it's great to see working on with our
open source teams on the shader compiler
stuff have on the validation errors you
were seeing with the device physical
limits have you submitted an issue to
the open source get a project for the
Vulcan validation layers mmm there's a
github project for Vulcan validation
layers alright and you were saying there
was what they were not catching issues
with physical limits yes have you
submitted a bug to that github project
no because the state of the andrina
driver was so shaky that way okay I
understand that the validation leader
there's a different part from the driver
but for us that is it's not transparent
if we if we fought the validation layer
before the driver but this is one year
ago right even on the PC the validation
layer was not firing for some stuff
which was obvious then half a year ago
there was a moment where the validation
died a fire too much and now we have a
moment where the validation day is
probably in a good place
okay thanks regarding the PC validation
layer problems I think we submitted a
proposal they should be unified so
whatever you're seeing on PC should work
on Android as well